[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't go crazy
yes happy thursday everyone uh what a
what a great show we have bread bear is
here yes
i
think it's bret bear either that or it's
teddy ruxpin
just in case i put in new batteries okay
david mcdowell is here
i know
because i could smell the crawfish in
her purse
so as the country reels from a bizarre
historic raid of a former president's
house our current president leaves for
vacation let's hope he tries parasailing
or base jumping or even more dangerous
takes the stairs at the hotel
but he deserves a break for as you know
he's done so much
first he put on his jacket
this after he slow danced with it for 15
minutes first
but that was a crowning achievement of
his presidency so far just eclipsing
that time he made a solid boom boom
in the press office bathroom
well near the press office bathroom
sorry brett so uh after approximately
four minutes of actual work where his
hands were busier than a cnn producer on
bring your daughter to work day
biden hops on a plane
he hops on a plane and not just with dr
jill
you know the noted pediatric
neurosurgeon who discovered a cure for
hemorrhoids when joe accidentally sat on
a stack of bingo chips
he invited his son hunter to fly along
not sure hunter really needs a plane to
do that
but there he is with joe getting ready
to leave i think we have tape of the
actual flight with hunter
[Applause]
yep
frankly we've seen better behavior on
the lolita express
by the way he's not the only freeloading
family member who enjoys free trips on
your dime pelosi's son also accompanied
her on the recent trip to taiwan you
know the trip that almost caused a war
she wants us all to believe that even
though he and her husband have got
business dealings there that's just a
coincidence that's like hunter and joe
saying they just go to china for
authentic kung pao chicken
nancy said her son was there as her
escort to which hunter said damn that's
even too kinky for me
but i guess she's trying to save face
what's the point
no surprise though she's down to the
last three that she keeps in the fridge
every time she reaches for a pint of
chocolate haagen-dazs she's looking back
at herself
but what a stark contrast to how trump's
family got treated this week biden and
pelosi is flying around trump's house
gets raided
oh sorry did i say raided how dare you
say the lockstep lemmings working from
the same script
and i know donald trump is saying that
this is a raid but that's a gross
exaggeration we have to be careful not
to adopt
the term raid
this was not a raid it is not a raid
it's not a raid trump talks about a raid
on his home no man there was no raid on
your home let's be polite and call it a
search and not a raid it wasn't a raid
on his house no doors were kicked down
it's amazing how they sound all alike
so it's not a raid because no doors were
kicked down
see you
i don't think you need to kick a door
down when you're armed and the door is
already open for you you butt head
i'm sorry
is he butthead or beavis
i keep forgetting
too mean
and yeah it was just a search not a raid
more like an easter egg hunt a
bachelorette scavenger hunt it was early
trick-or-treating and they were just
dressed up as cops
so now the media cares about words
after completely mistreating the english
language like they were kevin spacey at
the little league world series
what are you moaning about
a woman's no longer a woman a recession
is no longer a recession now raid is a
search
so funny watching the media try to play
this off as a trifle when you know if it
happened to one of their own they'd blow
up like paul pelosi's airbag
wonder what he's up to
[Music]
he'll be out in no time
but maybe we'll see how they react when
inevitably it happens to hunter and joe
they assume they're above the law much
like most democrats when democrats are
in power but do they ever think ahead
they won't always be in power
of course the white house claims joe had
no idea of the raid on a living
president how amazing is that i mean i
get hiding things from joe you know like
his car keys
and ponytails
but this is kind of a big deal
i wonder
you know what's going on in mr biden's
neighborhood
[Music]
hi neighbor
look look you might heard about a raid
that wasn't any raid
there was no raid it was a uh
just a neighborly visit
it's a neighbor popping in on a neighbor
unexpected
it's fun you go through the closets and
uh
you know what's in my closet
a sweater
i love sweaters on you
i love coming home at the end of the
day putting on a sweater
hold on a second
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
meanwhile during all this hillary is
fundraising off her own crimes she's
selling merch off the back of the
mar-a-lago raid posting an image of a
new piece of clothing on her twitter
account which bore the slogan
but her emails a reference to the
scandal about her use of a private email
server for official communications which
she's mocking she promoted the 30 hat on
monday saying every hat sold would help
defend democracy fight for our values
and also hide the male pattern baldness
of every feminist
but her emails
so cute
why should she stop there i can see a
few more clinton-related swag along the
same lines as butter emails how about
but her blue dress
but
but his missing cigar
but her getting shellacked in 2016.
and finally
i know this one will take up a lot of
room on the hat but got to do it but
bill goes to pedophile island and
epstein gets murdered
i'm kidding
i kid the old bag
fact is there different rules for these
elites than there are for others say
what you will about trump he was the
opposite of elite next to jay-z or dr
dre he's the most street-wise
billionaire ever and that's why they
hated him like kill mead's tapeworm they
couldn't control him
hence we now hear about there being an
fbi informant in his own house it's
pretty gross right but what do you
expect from a government that helped
organize the kidnapping of michigan
governor gretchen whitmer
gavin newsom would have been so much
easier
you just approach him with a van full of
hair
gel but it's crazy you can now spy on
the next prez provided he's not a damn
but if you can't find a crime then you
can create it the only problem is it's
going to come back to haunt you
right if the republicans take back the
house then they should raid bidens i can
just picture it fbi guys leaving with 15
boxes of oatmeal denture cream and
coloring books
but as hunter biden once said as he
entered the bunny ranch game on [ __ ]
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guest
he's covered more news than a parent
with diarrhea host of special report
bret bear
she's nuttier than a porta potty at a
peanut festival box business anchor
tagging mcdowell
she's like the magna carta difficult to
read and covered in dust boxes
contributor cat tim
and anacondas are his dental floss nice
massive sidekick in the nwa world
television champion tyrus
let me just say that
i think you brought the heat tonight oh
thank you i mean this was a top-notch
monologue i love the show but i'm always
amazed that administration officials
come on my show after watching the
monologue
it's truly yeah it is kind of strange
you know that some of the things i'm
doing but i know you're trying to butter
me up because you didn't read the topics
i read true
in between the show i read you know you
don't have to read all you got to do is
say what you said already today that's
what everybody does
okay
now what do you where do you see this
going right i mean it's do you think
there's actually going to be something
there because if there's nothing there
then marlin merrick garland looks pretty
bad really bad yeah i mean if it does
not deliver it looks really bad the
attorney general said that they filed to
unseal this search warrant that's the
next battle and it's going to come to a
head tomorrow yeah i couldn't understand
any of that legal stuff to be honest
with you like it the warrant isn't the
thing it's the affidavit right we were
going around and around and around the
five and i'm like get me the hell out of
here yeah the judge was against heroin
harold they do they do it it's like you
know what just get a room
i think it's it's going to be
fascinating tomorrow but listen the
bottom line is if it's about documents
and classified documents and whether he
should have them or not
uh i think there's a lot of people that
say there's got to be more there yeah
you know uh degan um you have a choice
you can talk about that you could talk
about hillary trying to make some dough
you can talk about anything you want
except what happened in the green room
that was not my fault
well since you opened comparing me to a
port-a-john full of
um
did i yeah and yeah you did and i had a
peanut butter since you booked the chief
political
correspondent or anchor that's anchor
yeah
um you know look at the big brain on
brett
um i'm just gonna sit over here and work
up some tata and pick up trump jokes and
just pick my teeth and glare at brett
and make him uncomfortable i can hit
i just these are politicians on the left
that deserve comeuppance one just stone
cold stupidity
joe biden and familia go to kiawah
island south carolina in the middle of
august nobody on the planet does that
it's muggy buggy you can't play golf
because the sweat runs from your armpits
all the way down the club
and then hillary she's thinking in her
mind she's going to get back in the game
and she hasn't dumped that drooling
walrus of a husband yet
that's true
he's still there okay now i'll shut up i
think
i applaud
what do you think tyrus i think dana's
gonna kick your ass after the show
i'm going to open chess and kick center
person yeah
no you're good i got okay thanks man oh
you'll defend him but not me no you you
got it coming yeah um no you said her
purse was full of a bag of crawfish
that's uh louisiana that's not a
compliment
you're never gonna go why thank you
[Laughter]
yeah women smell like seafood that's a
real fun joke yeah
yeah that's not what i did i could be i
bro i would be on an ocean for five
weeks with no roof and sitting next to a
woman and i still wouldn't say hey yeah
you smell like puppies
why is she's eating a raw shark in her
teeth people would mean to i still would
say wow is that lemon i'm
i'm a patriot you can't insult me you're
wearing a merrick garland
you know i just
i think it's important that we remember
uh we got to let this go i i just
when we when november comes we got to
get to work we can't waste time chasing
up what are we going to find in biden's
house like open cans of tapioca
everywhere
notes depends uh
angry post-its from his wife you know
maps to the bathroom like we're not
we're not going to find anything we want
to find the smart thing to do was to
usher him away because could you imagine
him answering the questions right now
raid yeah you know or search
he wouldn't be able to answer any of
those questions because they would be
raiding the white house searching for
him to bring him to the front so they
carried him away and let him stay there
while this blows up in their face so he
can try to say it's not him where's the
vp in all this that's a good question
where is she
i don't know cat yeah yeah i don't know
dad you have a report on her whereabouts
to read to us right now
no i don't think anyone does
we just know so little still i think and
the merrick garland hearing from him
today well what was that
he got up there and he's like yeah i did
it
uh it is a big deal i am gonna unseal
the warrant in the meantime please
remember that the fbi rules
and and we need more information because
now it's just people saying the same one
of two things back and forth it's like
well if this wasn't a big deal then they
really overdid it and that's gonna make
trump win or because they did all this
it must be a big deal and trump's going
to go to jail
and that's my impression of special
report
[Applause]
i was just going to say that this is
really insightful and you could
definitely be on the panel
it is wonderful
mr bear does a phenomenal i was almost
there i was almost there
i did not see that coming i don't
believe that i don't believe that that's
like all the guys after i got married
being like i should have taken you more
seriously
when i was on he even took the glasses
off me a question i was like yeah you
know you're in when brett favre takes
the glasses oh my god they're right over
here uh i didn't even
predict that this would go in such a
weird direction
but that's why this show rules okay hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else